on reste dans la littérature puisque
j'accueille estelle desanges
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
qu'est ce que c'est ça c'est un autre
d'or alors justement si une surprise
c'est quoi vous m'en donnez un autre
mais je savais que j'étais tout nu
oui privé de la donner oui non c'est
frédéric taddeï qui me donnait avant
mais vous n'avez pas eu officiellement
non un peu un ton prometteur d'or on
vous remercie les comités des odeurs qui
vous remet officiellement le hot d'or
d'honneur
[Applaudissements]
ah oui à mon nom et tout en battant avec
jardin puis la jeune homme avait ce qu
un seul match qui le méritent a renchéri
cui jian thierry nous sommes fiers de
vous remettre officiellement à hot d'or
d'honneur trophée réservé aux audacieux
aux précurseurs au visionnaire sachez
que depuis 1992 seuls trois
personnalités des médias ont reçu un
ours d'or d'honneur alain de greef
canal+
vous dessinez cinéma michel toulouse est
devenu c'est mauvais signe je peux faire
virer
merci et réveillère sont aujourd'hui les
géants de l'histoire
[Musique]
ça mérite un triomphe romain
à
merci
[Musique]
donc samedi prochain chez les 7 d'or moi
j'ai mode
merci merci beaucoup
catégorie double peiné annales
évidemment faut le gagner à pau le
méritais pas facile info faut que galea
oui je les remercie beaucoup bien alors
estelle desanges vous mesurer à m 73
vous peser 56 kg et vous fait 90 b et c
naturelle voilà je le dis aux nazis ça
va
alors vous êtes actrice de x vous êtes
donc top ten des pornostars française
assez rapidement d'ailleurs vous êtes
célibataire je le dis à mes amis moi je
suis marié bon mais bon vous vous êtes
saisis
bien vous allez aux oeufs d'or en 2000
en 2001 vous êtes dehors tous les ans
pratiquement 1 vous avez tout bonne dame
expo d'art vous ai déjà fait huit films
mais si vous êtes là c'est parce que
vous collaborez à une émission
littéraire
vous avez vu sa mère dans cette émission
l'émission de
l'émission de frédéric beigbeder sur
paris première qui s'appelle
délivrez-moi et et frédéric a choisi de
faire lire les passages érotiques des
livres des auteurs qu'il qu'il reçoit
par vous et c'est une très bonne idée
mais des fois vous faites plus aller
dans cette
voie là
j'ai bien à côté
il faut que vous lisiez se passait là là
ça semble s'il vous plaît soyez ma
délicatesse lui dis-je je baisse vos
genoux et votre front je saute ceux qui
ne m'appartient pas c'était un truc que
j'avais lu quelque part une formule de
dumas je crois dans une lette aïda
fériés ou peut-être à une autre elle me
regarda sans rire presque avec gravité
elle me caresser le visage avec un
mélange de douceur et de rapidité que
voulez vous nous dites elles vous
embrasser lui dis-je très vite en me
sentant rougir et bien me dit elle
immobile sans un geste est bien
embrasser mois
[Applaudissements]
et voilà donc c'est l'émission
littéraire de près avec bd et alors on
voit deux choses d'abord c'est que jean
d'ormesson et menotté donc c'est très
important et dont il fait quand même
partie de l'académie française bravo et
la deuxième chose c'est que les textes
érotiques d'ormesson lui dis-je me
tillie digit ii ça nous fait mal lui en
me sentant j10
vous allez voir
estelle tout à fait alors ça ça passe
demain donc voilà délivrez moi c'est sur
paris-première tous les dimanches à 19h
vous les trouvez comment les invités de
beigbeder l'ailé sollers les jeudis les
villes et il ya plein en fait je trouve
tout ça quand même assez coquin
ils ont tous dans leur roman un passage
assez haute surtout le vôtre jour temps
avec des mots très crus et quand il me
rend compte alors tout le monde ne sais
pas en fait que je fais du x parce que
je suis annoncé en tant que celle des
anges donc tout le monde connaît pas et
soit ils le savent après où ils ne
savent pas mentir ils sont un peu
intrigué ils disent pas tous autres
vidéos des en couverture d'autres vidéos
en plus bah oui on est seul en rapport
aux acteurs de l'entente entre les
entrées des écrivains et les acteurs de
films pornos ya beaucoup de différences
où il ya beaucoup de différences et je
veux te dire que c'est christelle à la
fin de du truc qu'elle a lu deux mois
elle avait une sorte de troubles mais
presque indiscernable béton mais [ __ ]
mais il est dans une imitation me
j'ai aimé giral tout gouvernant mer
le
il ya un an
bien alors vous vous êtes dans
l'émission de frédéric beigbeder mais
frédéric beigbeder est venu jouer dans
un film dans un film x où vous jouez
c'est un film de patrick cabanel qui
s'appelle la fille du batelier la fille
du batelier alors dans ce film c'est
incroyable parce qu'avec bd mais il ya
aussi daniel karlin qui est un fameux
documentariste joue là